dustin may with his sixth start of the
season the dodgers
so far when he takes them out two gone
with a man at third in the batter
bizarronado
in the stretch nolan hits it to the
right side backhanded on the line by
bellinger he'll beat nolan to the bag
and the rockies strand a runner at third
greenland looking for his third victory
this year an era right around two and a
half
now seeger coming up who has fared well
against freedom
six for 10. freeland's first one to
seeger is cracked through the left side
base hit
that's hustling first to third tapia's
throw off line
seeger now caught between first and
second and he is
going to get caught in a run down
allowing betts to come in to score
and the dodgers lead one nothing the
seeger stays alive long enough for
mookie betts to come in and a play where
he started
at first base aggressive base running
all around
one-nothing game one away in the second
chris taylor comes up
eighth pitch lofted to right hillyard
drifting back on it's still
going it keeps carrying out of here home
run chris taylor
on a ball that just kept on riding the
humidity
to the opposite field for his second
home run of the season
dodgers take a two to nothing lead kyle
came with the changeup
taylor able to hit to all fields
left it up did freeland and taylor
polished it off
battle of texans here dustin may against
sam hilliard
and this ball hammered to deep right
field take a good look you won't see it
for long
wow sam hilliard has hit one to the
upper reaches of the right field
bleachers
two to one that sounded loud
yeah it did well and everybody in the
ballpark they knew immediately
once this ball went off the sands back
so two down for the rockies and that'll
bring up daniel murphy
and murphy lines the ball to center
field
daniel had some good swings last night
with some good swings in his first ap
tonight so a two-out single for murphy
gonna bring up mcmahon the kick in the
pitch
swing and a chopper to the right side
that's taken by hernandez quick throw to
first
and no damage done for the rockies
middle of the fourth dodgers two
rockies one tying on a board with one
away in the fifth inning for the
nine-hitter walters
there goes the runner throw from barnes
hillyard is stolen second for the
rockies two for two in the stolen base
attempts tonight
pretty big league kick pretty slow to
the plate it's a very nice throw from
austin barnes
that base was stolen off of dustin may
needless to say
big hitter here for may as he tries to
get through five innings with the lead
two balls two strikes and a ground ball
backhanded stabbed by hernandez throws
to first and gets him
what a play by [ __ ] hernandez going to
the backhand
then he stumbled althea briefly still
had time to throw out tapia
a terrific play turned in by [ __ ]
hernandez
dustin may's evening is over but another
strong start for him goes five
innings on 81 pitches continues the
trend of allowing
two or fewer runs per outing goes to
third
tying run down 90 feet away aronado
coming up and he's over two
pitch denolen is a fly ball to
right field betts makes the catch story
tags here comes the throw to the plate
it is not in time nolan aronado delivers
a
sacrifice fly and the rockies have tied
the game at two
nolan did the job would rather have had
the base hit for sure but he got the run
in on a productive out
and instead of tony walters it'll be
matt kemp coming to the plate as a pinch
hitter with the go ahead run at third
kemp back in from the right side and
trynan's 3-1 he overthrew it and it goes
past the catcher barnes
coming in to score with a slide is ryan
mcmahon
the rockies will take it they have the
lead three to two in the seven
and the bases are full with nobody out
here in the seventh
here's taylor who has a home run against
el monte in his career
3-1 that is slotted to second speared by
mcmahon the story for one a double play
but they tie the game
turn her into score it's 3-3 so in a tie
game with the bases loaded it's up to
barnes
one-two pitch with the bases loaded
slider strike three called
yancy almonte rings up austin barnes and
leaves the bases full
tied at three to the bottom of the ninth
in bellinger to lead it off
here's the 1-0 i fly ball to right that
sends
hilliard back at the one it is gone
and the dodgers have wanted fashion
thankfully for cody it was the home run
signal on the first socially distance
walk-off celebration